one of the most famous competition shows
of all time American Idol may just be
coming back to TV now there were rumors
that NBC wanted it and now we're hearing
they may have to put up a fight it's
such a part of my life it could come
back in some other form somewhere else
NBC and Fox now locked in a bidding war
to bring Idol back while Fox wouldn't
comment on the new report a source tells
ET if the show comes back it wouldn't be
until 2018 so why would n be see who
already has ratings powerhouse the voice
even want to revive rivals show idols
it's a less is more approach right now
the voice turns out two seasons a year
and this would actually help the network
cut costs
The Voice coaches earn a reported 13
million per season new judges for Idol
would likely earn less and all this may
actually be welcome news for new dad
Adam Levine rumored now to want to only
do one voice season per year it's so
many singers every day and it just
becomes one and I've done them 12 times
but has former host Ryan Seacrest been
dropping keys to an idol comeback all
along
Seacrest out he changed that famous
sign-off to this during last April's
series finale goodnight America for now
Oh Never Say Never
I would love to host that show
you